>> Tucker: A SIGNIFICANT STORY
THE MEDIA HAVE ALL BUT IGNORED.
HE SOUTH AFRICA IS A DIVERSE
COUNTRY BUT THE SOUTH AFRICAN
GOVERNMENT WOULD LIKE TO MAKE IT
MUCH LESS DIVERSE.
IN EMBATTLED MINORITY OF FARMERS
IS BEING TARGETED IN A WAVE OF
BARBARIC AND HORRIFYING MURDERS.
BUT INSTEAD OF PROTECTING THEM,
THE GOVERNMENT JUST PASSED A LAW
ALLOWING IT TO SEIZE THEIR FARMS
WITHOUT ANY COMPENSATION BASED
PURELY ON THEIR ETHNICITY AND
DISTRIBUTE THOSE TWO MORE
FAVORED GROUPS.
THOUSANDS OF ALREADY MIGRATED
OUT OF THE COUNTRY BUT THEY
STRUGGLED TO ATTRACT ANY
SYMPATHY ABROAD FOR SOME REASON.
DEPUTY CEO OF THE SOUTH AFRICA
CIVIL RIGHTS GROUP.
HE WAS JUST IN THE UNITED STATES
TO MEET WITH A NUMBER OF
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS.
ALSO TOOK A MOMENT TO TALK TO
US.
HERE'S PART OF WHAT HE SAID.
>> THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Tucker: WHAT YOU DESCRIBE
IN THIS BOOK, IT IS ORGANIZED
BUT IN SOME SENSE INTENTIONAL
CAMPAIGN TO CRUSH A RACIAL
MINORITY WITHIN YOUR COUNTRY AND
THE GOVERNMENT SEEMS ONBOARD
WITH IT.
IS THAT AN OVERSTATEMENT?
>> WITH THE BOOK IS ABOUT, IT'S
ABOUT GOVERNMENT COMPLICITY IN
THE FORM OF ATTACKS AND MURDERS.
THE LAST TWO DECADES THERE HAVE
BEEN -- WE BELIEVE WE HAVE
REASON TO SAY IT'S MAY BE
DOWNPLAYED A LITTLE.
THERE'S BEEN ABOUT TO GO FARM
ATTACKS EVERY DAY AND TWO FARM
MURDERS EVERY WEEK IN
SOUTH AFRICA AND IN THE BOOK I
HIGHLIGHT ACTUALLY TEN DIFFERENT
REASONS WHY WE THINK THE
GOVERNMENT IS COMPLACENT.
IT STRETCHES FROM REASONS
INCLUDING -- FOR EXAMPLE IN 2007
IT WAS A 25% INCREASE IN THESE
ATTACKS AND THE SOUTH AFRICAN
GOVERNMENT RESPONDED SAYING WE
ARE NOT GOING TO RELEASE ANY
MORE STATISTICS ABOUT THIS.
AND ALSO, WHICH IS VERY
CONCERNING IS THE HATE SPEECH IN
SOUTH AFRICA.
THAT'S THE TITLE OF THE BOOK AS
WELL.
IT'S A VERY POPULAR SONG WHICH
IS STILL BEING SUNG.
IT SUNG AT POLITICAL RALLIES AND
ITS REFERRING TO A PARTICULAR
CULTURAL GROUP IN SOUTH AFRICA.
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF WAYS IN
WHICH --
>> Tucker: I THOUGHT THAT HATE
SPEECH WAS NOW A CRIME
PUNISHABLE BY PRISON TIME IN
SOUTH AFRICA.
ARE ANY OF THE PEOPLE WHO SAY
THIS ARRESTED?
>> TO HAVE HATE SPEECH DECLARED
CRIME PUNISHABLE BY PRISON TIME,
THERE'S A BILL ON THE TABLE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MOTIVATION
AROUND IT, IT'S CLEAR THAT, VERY
CLEAR THAT GOVERNMENT ARE
PUSHING THIS DON'T REGARD THIS
AS HATE SPEECH.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, THEY'VE
BEEN ARGUING THAT IT'S NOT HATE
SPEECH IN COURT.
THEY WOULD ARGUE THAT THEY HAVE
A RIGHT TO SING ABOUT KILLING
FARMERS AND THEY WOULD SAY IT'S
AN EXPRESSION OF FREEDOM OF
SPEECH.
>> Tucker: SO NOW THE
GOVERNMENT HAS ANNOUNCED THAT IT
PLANS TO PURSUE A POLICY OF
TAKING LAND AWAY FROM PEOPLE ON
THE BASIS OF THEIR SKIN COLOR.
DO YOU THINK WILL DO THAT?
>> THAT IS WHAT IS ADOPTED IN
OUR PARLIAMENT.
A MEASURE WAS ADOPTED THAT THE
CONSTITUTION HAS TO BE CHANGED
TO ALLOW FOR THE PRIVATE
PROPERTY WITHOUT COMPENSATION.
SAY THAT THIS WOULD TURN
SOUTH AFRICA INTO THE ULTIMATE
PARADISE IN THE GARDEN OF EDEN
AND DEPUTY PRESIDENT EVEN WENT
FURTHER SAYING THAT HE IS
BASICALLY TELLING WHITE FARMERS
THAT IF THEY DO NOT VOLUNTARILY
HAND OVER THEIR LAND TO BLACK
PEOPLE AND THERE WILL BE A
VIOLENT TAKEOVER.
THE SITUATION IS VERY DIRE IN
SOUTH AFRICA.
BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT THERE
IS STILL A PROCESS THAT HAS TO
BE FOLLOWED AND THAT'S WHY WE
ARE IN THE UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: WHAT I FIND SO
STRIKING IS THE RESPONSE FROM
EVERYONE ELSE AROUND THE WORLD.
THERE'S ALMOST NORMAL SNOW
COVERED THE AMERICAN MEDIA.
THE DESERVE IT BECAUSE OF WHAT
THEIR ANCESTORS DID.
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY IS
SIMILARLY SILENT.
HAVE YOU MET WITH ANY GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS HERE IN WASHINGTON
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN YOUR
COUNTRY?
>> THAT'S WHY WE ARE HERE.
WE ARE ABOUT TO MEET WITH SOME
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS AND IT'S
VERY UNFORTUNATE, THE SITUATION
THAT YOU'VE JUST MENTIONED.
ESPECIALLY IN SOUTH AFRICA IF
THERE'S A HIERARCHY OF
RECOGNITION.
SOME PEOPLE WHEN THEY ARE THE
VICTIMS IT'S ALL OVER THE NEWS
AND YOU HEAR ABOUT IT FREQUENTLY
AND OTHER PEOPLE, ESPECIALLY
FARMERS IN SOUTH AFRICA, WHITE
FARMERS IN PARTICULAR.
THEY WILL BE TORTURED TO DEATH
AND IT RECEIVES VERY LITTLE NEWS
COVERAGE AND THAT'S
UNFORTUNATELY THE SITUATION
ABROAD AS WELL, WHICH IS WHY WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL TO BE HAVING
THIS.
>> Tucker: A GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL IN AUSTRALIA SAID
PUBLICLY MAYBE WE OUGHT TO ALLOW
ASYLUM TO PEOPLE BEING PEW
PERSECUTED FOR THEIR SKIN COLOR
AND HE WAS BASICALLY LAUGHED AT
AND THEN ATTACKED BY YOUR
GOVERNMENT FOR SAYING THAT.
>> HE WAS ATTACKED AND THEY SAID
THAT HE SHOULDN'T SAY THAT
BECAUSE THEY WERE PROVIDING HIM
WITH FALSE INFORMATION.
THE INFORMATION IS GOVERNMENT
STATISTICS.
WHOEVER SPEAKS OUT AGAINST THIS
JUST FOR BEING -- WE'VE BEEN
ACCUSED OF TREASON, PEOPLE
THREATENING US SAYING THEY WILL
WAIT FOR US AND ATTACK US.
THE PRESIDENT AND PARLIAMENT
CALLING ON US TO GO BACK TO
SOUTH AFRICA.
WHENEVER YOU SPEAK OUT AGAINST
THIS, THERE IS VERY SERIOUS
BACKLASH.
>> Tucker: THIS IS NOT WHAT
NELSON MANDELA WANTED.
>> IT'S THE EXACT OPPOSITE THAN
WHAT HE WANTED.
HE SPOKE ABOUT A FREE COUNTRY IN
WHICH PEOPLE WERE NOT JUDGED BY
THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN.
HE EVEN WANTED FARM ATTACKS TO
BE A PRIORITY CLAIM.
WHEN HIS PRESIDENCY WAS OVER
THEY DEPRIORITIZED IT.
>> Tucker: SO YOU JUST WATCH
SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAPPEN IN A
NEIGHBORING COUNTRY, ZIMBABWE,
WHICH WENT FROM BEING ONE OF THE
RICHEST ONE OF THE POOREST IN
THE WORLD BECAUSE OF ATTACKS AND
BECAUSE OF THE THEFT OF PRIVATE
PROPERTY.
IS THE ANC, THE RULING PARTY IN
SOUTH AFRICA AWARE OF THAT
LESSON?
>> THEY ARE, BUT REAL COMMUNISM
HAS NEVER BEEN TRIED, THAT'S
WHAT THEY KEEP SAYING.
IT FAILED IN ZIMBABWE, IT FAILED
IN CUBA, IT FAILED IN VENEZUELA,
HE FAILED IN RUSSIA, IT FAILED
IN CHINA, ALL OF THOSE COUNTRIES
AND THEY ARE BASICALLY SAYING
ARE WE GOING TO TRY THE SAME
THING AND THIS TIME IT'S GOING
TO WORK.
>> Tucker: BASICALLY IT'S
IMMORAL TO TALK TO YOU AND HEAR
STORIES LIKE THIS FOR NO REASON
THAT NOBODY BOTHERS EVER REALLY
TO EXPLAIN BUT IT'S JUST
UNDERSTOOD.
IF YOU COULD SPEAK TO OUR MEDIA
AND PEOPLE WHO ARE DISMISSING
YOUR CLAIMS AS FOLLOWS, WHAT
WOULD YOU SAY?
>> I THINK THERE ARE THREE
THINGS.
FIRSTLY, EVERYTHING WE SAY IS
FACT BASED.
IT'S BASED ON RESEARCH.
BUT IN TERMS OF WHAT WE HOPE TO
ACHIEVE AND WHAT PEOPLE CAN DO,
PEOPLE WHO WANT, WE WANT THEM TO
CALL ON THE SOUTH AFRICAN
GOVERNMENT TO SAY YOU WANT TO
EXPROPRIATE THOSE.
NUMBER TWO, WE ARE SPEAKING WITH
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT AND ASKING
THEM TO PUT PRESSURE ON THE
SOUTH AFRICAN GOVERNMENT, WHICH
COULD BE DONE IN A VARIETY OF
WAYS.
AND NUMBER THREE, MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA,
THE BEST THING YOU CAN DO TO
HELP US IS TO TALK ABOUT THIS,
TO TALK ABOUT IT ON PUBLIC
PLATFORMS AND IN THAT WAY TO
CONTINUE TO PUT PRESSURE ON THE